And we are
All right. Um we'll get to 10:05. Um so
welcome everyone to our next episode of
AI that works.
Our whole goal here is always the same,
write code that works and see if we can
do some incredible things with AI that
doesn't
that doesn't depend on waiting for
GPT-26.
My name is Vaibhav. I'm one of the
creators of Amel.
And my wonderful co-host is Dexter. I'll
allow him to introduce himself.
Uh I am working on uh my name is Dexter.
I build things.
Uh that's probably all you need to know.
Uh try to help people build very cool AI
stuff.
Um whether it's agents, whether it's
pipelines, whether it's full stack
applications.
Uh
Yeah, that's that's I'm not going to go
deep into it. Um real quick
announcements, just updates um for those
of y'all, I'll just say it again one
more time in the stream is like so we're
going to do these we do these every
Tuesday at 10:00 a.m. Um and then we
launched the I guess this is good
context to lead into where we're going.
Um we publish the videos Fridays at 8:00
a.m.
Um and we will push up everything in
this show will be in the GitHub repo
here. Uh I'll put it in the Zoom chat.
So all the notes from previous episodes,
everything will be live by Friday.
Um
I have a short link, but this is just
the GitHub repo. Oh, that's not right.
Sorry.
hlyr.dev/aitw.
Um that'll take you to all the previous
sessions and you can watch the
recordings. You can see the notes and
the notes from this session will be
there and any useful links and things
like that and all of the code.
Yeah. And it takes a lot of work.
The reason that we try and share all the
code is honestly because there's a lot
of people out there talking about how to
go how you can theoretically build
things.
We just want to see the code. We're all
engineers or eventually everyone will be
an engineer. Today everyone uses Excel,
tomorrow everyone's going to write code.
It's just the way it is. We might as
well share all the code and share what
we can learn along the way.
Um with that in mind, today's topic is
one that Dexter and I have
we're very very very very excited about.
Um all this work that we do every week
is really freaking annoying sometimes.
The this actual recording
Woah. We love doing it. We love doing
it.
But it's a lot of work.
Uh and I think the part that's the most
annoying is the manual part of like
downloading the videos, uploading them
to YouTube, getting the transcript,
setting up the email afterwards. And
sometimes you probably notice like four
or five episodes didn't send an email
out. That's cuz that's not what we love
doing. We just like writing code. That's
the thing that we love the most. So we
thought, why don't we actually go put
some of the practices that we've talked
about in previous episodes into practice
and build a pipeline that can go do
something.
And the thing that we thought what was
worth doing
was
really building the AI content pipeline.
So what we're going to start off with
today is
we're going to screen share. We're going
to show you a live demo of what works
today, what doesn't work today. Then
we're going to talk about the
architecture diagram on a whiteboard.
And then afterwards, we're going to go
make the pipeline better.
Cuz I think those are the steps that I
find to be personally really
interesting.
So with that, let's kick it off. Um
today's is going to be even more
interactive than normal. So if you have
questions, please hop off mute. Just
come and ask yourselves. That's why we
do this over Zoom and not a podcast
recording software or anything else
because it's just way faster when people
get to ask real questions along the way.
Um with that, let's get started.
And I will say, I am one of the least
vibe coding people out there. I don't
really vibe code. Um
but thanks to Dexter and actually uh
credit to my cousin as well.
I'm a big believer everyone should be
vibe coding uh a lot more than they
think they should. If you were vibe
coding before, you probably should buy
code more than you thought you were. And
here's what we were able to do with this
pipeline.
So, right over here, the first thing you
notice is we are able to sync with Zoom
and actually record all the previous
recordings up here.
So, we can actually see any of the
previous recordings. You can see one
right over here. This current one is
literally going on right now. We started
the recording and pops in immediately.
We can see our previous recordings and
we can just import and process them.
What happens when you import and process
a recording? I'll just kick one off.
Um
is
real quick call out. It says the title
is still says Cracking the Prompting
Interview. I think that's like inherited
from from Baml, but this is this current
episode.
Uh oh Or inherited from Luma or
whatever.
From Yeah, when Luma created the Zoom,
it left the title.
Exactly. So, we'll just start off this
one. AI that we're designing emails,
we'll create the import.
So, now you can see the video being
processed.
This is one we already did all the work
in the email for, but um the idea is you
going forward we would use this.
So, while it's processing, I'll let it
kick itself off and you can actually see
what it's doing. When When it's
processing, it's actually going ahead
and downloading the full video.
And it's going to go ahead and
eventually it'll get to a point where
once the video is downloaded, it'll
actually upload itself
to uh YouTube automatically. It'll
download the full transcript. Then it'll
start producing key points and video
summaries.
And then after it's done, it'll actually
produce like an email draft. I guess I
don't have that here.
Uh this one didn't finish. Let me
Once it's done, it'll actually produce
like an email draft of what to go send
out.
I'll produce like an X post that we can
go copy and paste and post out there and
it'll produce like LinkedIn content as
well.
So, this is what we mean by
multi-channel content. Download a
60-minute video.
Uh go for it. Go summarize it. Get the
key topics and takeaways and go draft
things.
Now,
what you'll notice here is that this
email does read like AI still. It's
still not very
email sucks, dude.
Exactly. So, we're going to talk about
how to make it better.
Did you even look at the prompt?
No, I didn't. I've I've built the whole
thing. Because the point What I really I
think what this is the point I want to
stress today is before you can even work
on your AI part of your pipeline,
you're not even at the point where you
can start working on that. What you need
is infrastructure that you can actually
iterate on.
And if we hadn't built this whole system
up that could do the glue code,
building the AI part is completely
useless.
Because it doesn't really matter. I
still need to build the rest of it. And
the rest of it is actually critical to
my iteration loop. And we talk about
this in our eval's video a lot,
where if you don't If you're eval'ing,
you should spin up a quick little UI to
go determine if your eval's are correct
or not and go compare the differences.
If you're building a pipeline, you
should be doing the same thing.
And right here, you can see the same
thing. It actually is going ahead and
let me see if the socket connection
works. Yeah, there we go.
It's actually going to It's actually
able to also stream out the outputs if I
wanted to, which is really useful for me
to iterate a little bit faster along the
way.
I'll pause really fast. Questions so
far?
Cool.
Let's keep on going.
How long was it end to end did you say?
3 hours or something to build this?
I logged off after 3 hours. I don't know
how late Five O'Clock was up last night.
It took a total of 6:00 p.m. to about
2:30 a.m.
Um
combined with an hour and a half break
in the middle.
I slept Oh, Renee.
You're You're new to the session.
Renee, you got to go watch the other
episodes. We don't We don't do
frameworks here.
Um and the reason we don't do them is
more often than not, they just get in
the way and they make it harder to go do
things rather than easier.
With that, let's talk about what this
architecture diagram ends up looking
like.
Um
unless there's a couple more questions
about this itself.
Um
Yeah, let's let's uh
let's draw it out, and then let's let's
make the let's make the actual AI
generated stuff not suck.
I agree.
All right.
Pull this down.
Oops. Why is my mouse not working?
We did record the whole thing. You can
watch it at 2x speed. We'll post it.
Well, not the whole thing. Yeah, we're
going to we're going to post the
recording. I uh yeah, there's I got to
we got to edit a couple things out, but
yeah, you can you can watch the the
beginning.
All right.
So, let's talk about what the
architecture of this whole system is,
and how we actually did this. And we
will probably try and record more of our
coding sessions along the way.
Uh if people find it interesting, we can
invite you to come and watch us code in
real time as well, uh along with just uh
going to go do that.
So, there's actually there's actually
three main parts to this system.
And I think it's it's useful to draw
them out into three different systems.
This one is the database.
Okay. So, another thing that we did is
what we said is
we will actually not allow the uh front
end to really get data from the back
end. It's not allowed to. It's allowed
to issue requests to the back end, but
it can't get data from the back end.
The back end is allowed to read and
write from the database.
And the front end is allowed to read
from the database.
So, we get really, really nice queries
of how things are being built out. And
the reason that this is so important
is because if you're doing something
like streaming or interactive UIs,
building out the system to from your
back end that communicates with your
front end is a pain in the ass.
And if you're doing it on a lot of
different places all the time,
this is what real-time databases were
made for.
Just use them, and you can solve a lot
of your pain.
And you might run into a situation
basically the
the data API is just your database
schema. The front end just needs to know
the raw schema, and it can query
whatever you want to expose to it,
right?
Yes, exactly. So as long as you have
like a view in your database that is a
accessible,
uh that is read readable, and you have
like some materialized view on it that
is secure, doesn't have anything like
PII data or something along that, or at
least require like authenticated users
to access it,
then you can go ahead and go access this
along the way.
Um it does require some consideration of
exactly how you do it. The easiest way
to do it is a materialized view if you
want to do it securely on your actual
data, so you can go configure that in a
good way.
Um but once you can go do that, now
you're able to build a pipeline that is
mostly just workflows in your back end
that is issuing work at one after
another.
So for example,
And you kind of get you get rid of this
like state machiney thing where the
front end's like pushing data and then
fetching it back out of the back end.
It's kind of this unidirectional flow,
and I think a lot of like this happened
in React. We had React for like a year
and a year and a half, and then people
realized like the current back end
paradigm in React, which at the time was
things like Backbone.js and and and
things like that, just didn't work well
for the amount of complexity people were
using to add React into their apps. And
all this stuff like Flux came out, and
there was explosion of like six
different frameworks all came out that
one summer of like how do you do this
unidirectional data flow? Because it was
what worked for real-time dynamic
applications.
Yeah, and this is a pattern that we've
seen happen a lot. Like we just find it
way easier what you and this is similar
to video games and all these other
things that you might want to do. Uh
where what you really want to go do is
you have some what I would call like
state of truth that is represented here.
And all you want to do is you want to
render the truth as fast as possible to
the front end.
And it's really easy to do that
when you're able to go ahead and
actually model the truth in a way that
is representative in the way that the
front end can use it. And the challenge
then becomes building a schema that
everything else can go use correctly. So
you do have to plan that out a little
bit, but I think it pays for itself um
personally in terms of like the
developer ease and how easy this ends up
being.
This also does really nice
componentization for both like
paralyzing workflows in terms of how
many people can work on it and not just
people, but agents. It makes it way
easier for my
uh front end to actually understand what
it's rendering.
If now the one part that we run into is
in order to go do this, what you'll find
is you have data models
um
Uh sorry, I'll draw another rectangle.
You have some data models
that you're saving into your database
into here and these data models both
have to be used by Python and written
from Python and then they also have to
be used and written by TypeScript.
Having some way to keep these in sync is
also really important. Otherwise you end
up again in a world of pain and that
doesn't really work.
And figuring out which side you're on is
really really important of how you go do
that, but once you can nail that down,
your iteration loop is going to be
really fast and adding new features, as
we'll see today when we add another
feature such as chapter summary into our
system, becomes a thing that you can
just write code trivially.
And you don't have to think about it
anymore uh because your agent kind of
understands the architecture of what
you're building out and it's so nicely
componentized that it doesn't have room
for making mistakes along the way.
It's like an API you've basically built
in an API contract. If your front end
was both reading and writing to the
database,
you now have a choice every the agent
now is making an implicit decision of do
I do this in the front end or do I do
this in the back end?
And that's a choice.
And it might make one choice correctly,
one choice wrong. But the more you go
along, the more choices that will be
made incorrectly just by volume and by
the nature of it happening
automatically. By doing this, we make a
very clear direction of what Dexter is
saying. It's very easy what to do. The
front end's job is to render the content
and issue new background tasks. The back
end's job is to plumb and churn on data
and eventually write updates to the
database.
The database's job is to send data out
to the front end as soon as possible.
And now it's very clear what we have to
go represent along the way.
Um
With that, let's talk about some more uh
routes. Um
I do have a very opinionated stance on
what's a great data model agnostic
libraries we'll see today. Um but we'll
show that in a second. We'll show the
full code.
Um so what's the what's the APIs that we
actually have? We have a couple APIs
that we defined. Um
We have Dexter, do you remember what
they are by
video We have one API to like submit
a new request. Uh did you push the
latest code? I can pull it down and and
pull that out real quick.
Um yeah, let me do that actually. I
don't think I did.
Um oh, I might have.
I guess I did.
Uh cool. I will get the API endpoints.
Turns out there's uh AI is pretty good
at generating a list of API endpoints.
Provide feedback.
Um
and then we What we do is we submit a
new request, provide feedback, um
get list of videos. So, there are some
things that we do from the back end.
Um
yeah, list of videos, provide feedback.
And then what's the other stuff? I think
there's one more, get title. Oh, there
we go.
I don't know why I didn't do that.
Okay.
So, these are basically all the APIs
that we have.
Um we did have to build one integration
cuz the way we get actual Zoom API
calls, we don't want to do that in a
real-time database. We want the back end
to have access. So, this is something
that the front end queries from
directly.
This is the way to add feedback to a
draft. So, if you don't like an email,
um what we're able to do
is we can just go through and say like,
"Oh,
um I can just leave feedback and say,
'Eh,
this
is
not long enough
Dude, you got to make it more uh gen
alpha.
enough
uh emojis.'
And I'll just refine the email. And what
this will do is this will commit a task,
and eventually the email will get
refined along the way.
Uh and I did not actually
I don't know
Well, I don't know if you're planning on
um getting to this, but I think it'd be
really helpful to kind of see the
sequence diagram or the flowchart of
like how how stuff flows through the
system.
Yeah, I was going to get to that once I
show all the routes. Okay, cool. Cool.
So, and then we basically have all these
routes. So, let's um let's look at what
this actually ends up looking like in a
sequence flow in that case. So, we have
all these things. So, the first thing
that we have is Oops, I can't draw it
there.
I will try and do this side by side. I'm
missing a couple endpoints. One sec. Oh,
you are? Okay, that's what I thought. It
looks like you don't have the
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, the first five were actually the
most important.
When did I lose this?
Oh, sorry.
I have to adjust my Okay, there we go.
Um so, what we have here looks like
this.
The first step that happens is the back
end submits a task to say like I want to
process this specific meeting ID.
Uh the front end submits a task to
submit I want to process meeting ID. The
back end then gets all the data submits
a background task, so it responds very,
very fast to the front end saying,
"Cool, I got you."
And then the background task will go
ahead and kick off and then say
something like
the following. Where it will say
something like um
download
download video plus transcript.
Um finding the video was a little bit
more complicated than I presume because
not all Zoom videos don't only have one
video, so they sometimes have multiple
because people start and stop the
recording and other things along the
way.
So, we have to go do that.
Then we will kick off a couple jobs in
parallel. One of them is upload
to YouTube.
And then simultaneously
we also kick off the
summarize uh summarize task.
Once the summarize task is done
we kick off three tasks in parallel
again.
Uh draft email
Does the summarize task also output the
like key points and stuff like that?
Exactly. That's what it outputs. It
outputs like a general summary of
everything.
Um
So, the database updates from each of
these is like basically like
mark uploaded in DB.
Exactly.
And then this is like uh add summary
points to DB.
Exactly. And actually this one streams
in, so I actually like save the whole
thing on every update of the tick of the
stream.
Yep. Um
Exactly. Um and technically there's a
special thing that I Oops.
There's one last thing that I do over
here, which is like
uh Oops.
I I mark I I mark the database as it's
done summarizing.
It's important that I can like mark the
state at any single one of them and
that's uh that that's something else I
had to do. Cuz once it was done
summarizing
actually
I I think that's actually worth maybe
taking a sec to drill into is just kind
of like having your kind of job system
just be a table with a bunch of nullable
columns and you can tell what's been
done just by what's set in the database
and in that way I mean it's it's not as
like robust as something like big and
like chunky like Temporal or something
like that, but it is honestly probably
good enough, especially if you're
building like internal tools for
yourself, um which is
uh
super super high leverage I think these
days. Um
just that idea of like a really simple
job system.
The problem that I ran into when I was
doing purely nullable fields is that it
wasn't I wasn't doing JSON parsing. Uh
sorry, like once I was streaming I had
something in there when I wasn't done.
So I actually needed to keep a status of
it. A little bit more.
I see.
Because like I needed to know the status
of like is it started? Is it streaming
or is it done?
And the status was really important.
Uh
and having it available was important to
actually show the UI there.
Um and then the other thing that I did
was I got bored, so I added one last
thing. I added uh while I was at it, I
was like, "Okay, let's just
Why not? We did all these three things."
So, I just asked it to
literally follow this example along the
way, and I said, "Draft a title for me."
after you're done.
Uh so, that became the next thing that
we did. So, now we had four pipelines
that could trigger and process.
Once this was done, I have another thing
I could do, which was a user
a favor.
Yeah. Sorry, do me a favor real quick.
Hit five.
And just change the arrow to this one
over here.
Cuz those macaroni Those mac macaroni
arrows arrows suck.
I agree. Oh, so you got to Yeah, if you
hit five twice, I think it cycles
through. It used to happen to me all the
time. Still happens to me all the time.
Thank you. This is why I'm really bad at
Excel raw.
Um then we get another So, this
pretty [ __ ] good, dude.
Now we have another request that the
user can do once all these are done. And
remember, all this is streaming to the
real-time database.
So, it's very, very easy for my front
end to render this because it's just
rendering a blob of JSON that is
strongly typed, and I know how to render
it, so it becomes trivial for me to go
render. I just build React components
for all those types.
Then I built the second part of the
pipeline,
which said like if the use user would
make like a draft ID,
content type,
and then their feedback. So, the user
wants to commit feedback to one of these
emails. So, I have each of these drafts
as an ID, they have a version history
and everything attached to it. There is
different content types and mediums, so
like email, X, and LinkedIn.
And once this happens, we do the same
exact thing that we were doing before.
Oops.
Where this time,
instead of our normal background, we
kick up another background process.
And this background process, again,
responds very, very fast to the LLM
saying, "Okay, cool. I'll I'll take care
of that for you."
And once that is done, it goes to
real-time database,
pulls out the draft,
pulls out the transcript,
uh
draft,
transcript,
and then issues that to a prompt,
saves a new version,
and then writes that to the database.
And that's all this pipeline is.
There's nothing fancy about this.
It's really just kicking off background
workers constantly to go do work for me
while I go and allow myself to iterate
fast
along the way.
Does this give everyone a good idea of
what the background pipeline looks like?
And how we're able to go and iterate on
this pipeline along the way?
So, in the first instance, when you
created the draft, did you use the
transcript or did you use the summary of
the transcript?
I just use I I I
At the time, I didn't actually think
about using the transcript, so I just
used the transcript. We can update that
to go use the transcript as well.
This is why the draft
summary?
Got it. Yeah, I only use the summary,
not the transcript. Sorry.
Uh this is why the these initial drafts
are bad.
That's uh so, like, when we go with
this, and we actually look at the UI on
here, uh where'd it go?
Okay, I guess it's here.
Um this is why the original draft was
really bad. And like now that I told it
to go and add more feedback with like
emojis, you can see it added more emojis
in this one.
But the first one didn't have any of
that. And like this it's going to be
bad. It doesn't have any of this. Like
it writes your name. I have to fill this
stuff out. It's kind of annoying.
Um, but that's because I have really
given it no context and the AI part of
this is not even close to done.
Okay, cool. So so to test this So to
test this what we're going to do is
we're going to change the prompt and
then we're going to re-import a whole
video from scratch and then we're going
to see if the drafts are better, right?
Well, we can just regenerate the
summary. But yes.
Uh, we don't actually have to regenerate
the summary.
No, that was your lead-in. You're This
is This is where we uh we go way down
into the inner loop and we say, "Hey,
okay, cool. Let's go get a real record
from the database and then like write a
test for it."
Yeah, let's go do that actually. That's
the uh that's the old way. That's how I
would have done this a year ago. It's
just kind of test the thing end-to-end,
right?
Well, I I think that's the point. Like
let's show the end-to-end testing loop
and let's show the faster loop once
we're able to go do it.
So in this case, uh does that answer
your question, Vijay?
Yes, it does. Thank you.
Perfect. Yes. So now let's go ahead and
actually go and try and make some of
this pipeline better. Now there's a
couple of questions that asked about how
do we keep all this data in sync and
everything. So I'll just show you a
little bit more of the code and what it
ends up looking like because I think it
is useful to have some dive through
before we go and change a bunch of
things.
I'm also going to show how to go make
this work with Claude code and how to go
edit it to add a new pipe part of the
pipeline. Cuz the problem that I
actually noticed the most if you
actually look at some of the prompts,
they're just long. It just like doesn't
really talk about the real part of it.
Like it adds the feedback, it dumps the
transcript in there, which is fine, but
it's like
it it it doesn't really really really
understand what I mean by actually
making the prompt better.
Uh and what makes a good email. It's
same thing with this. It's like
it doesn't really understand about what
is a good Twitter thread when it does
this along the way. Cuz I don't think
this is really
It's It's giving it instructions about
what to do, not so much about like what
looks good, like what good looks like.
Exactly. And like but we can't focus on
what good looks like until we have the
mechanics of what to do really plumbed
in because I will spend a lot more time
iterating on the infrastructure. Like I
said, this took about 8 hours of work to
go from nothing to a fully generating
SAS flow that does this.
Um and that's worth doing.
But if I just built the AI part, I
wouldn't even if I thought this was
useful, I won't Dexter and I wouldn't
actually use this app. It would be
unusable. So we need to build a flow
that made sense for us in a way and then
we can go and make the AI part better.
Otherwise, you just have a bunch of
Python scripts that you don't actually
use and now they're trash.
And that was a waste of time.
So building the whole thing out is worth
it because then you can decide how to
actually design the AI along the way.
Um with that, let's talk about some of
this stuff. So this data model is called
Twitter thread.
This is what we're rendering both in the
back end and the front end.
And I'll show you how this gets used
in the front end.
Uh and I'm just going to exclude all the
battle plan code.
Oops.
Um All we do is we just regenerate types
and we generate types for both front end
and back end types and now we just use
them here. So in this case, we have a
Twitter thread. This gets imported and
now my UI component just renders this.
So what's really nice about this is if I
tell the model to go change what it
means to be a Twitter thread, my front
end will break at compile time
and now it will go actually Claude code
can go fix it for me. So I actually get
types that are in sync perfectly along
the way
rather than anything else.
Um, and the way that I'm able to do this
is I just code gen both types. I code
gen the Python versions that my back end
uses and writes to the database.
And then I code gen the React versions
that my front end uses. And I just use
the same types to basically issue the
glue code along the way.
So, I think Joe asked the question
earlier of what I used to go do that,
and this is what I found worked for me.
Um, and then
Okay, so you have the back end the back
end is getting the transcript and then
it's passing it to methods in BAML in
Python with using Pydantic. And then
when it gets them back, it's storing
those to the database. And because it's
all generated from the same BAML kind of
contract API specification, when those
same kind of JSON objects get served to
the front end, the front end can use the
generated client uh, that that that got
made from the exact same specification
to render those things and have type
safety around them and know exactly what
they look like when they're being
rendered.
Exactly.
Exactly. Cool.
So, you get really, really convenient
type systems along the way.
Um,
with that, let's focus on actually
making some of these prompts better.
Um, so the first thing that we'll notice
is generate a custom Twitter thread.
Um,
one thing that I did not do because I
was live coding,
um,
I found this helpful writing the UI much
better.
Um, the V0 UI is okay, but the problem
is when you're actually syncing a back
end and front end together, using V0 is
a really, really
it's hard.
Uh, because what I need to do is
find a way to
Well, you have to find a way to make
sure V0 fully understands the like data
contract and the models that are
available, right?
Exactly. Otherwise, it just changes
things, and then I'm stuck in a I'm
iterating way slower.
And it's fine if your entire app is
purely built in TypeScript, but if you
have long-running workflows, it's not
going to be built purely in like your
next JS app won't define everything.
Um and like that just doesn't work.
So, that's why I had to go down this
road. And I think a lot of people are
using like non uh TypeScript backends or
they have non-TypeScript backends
already that they want to pull data
from.
And it's just useful to have one data
architecture that does this. You can
still do it in V0, but it's just the it
doesn't have the context.
And it breaks the types and my whole app
is broken, that sucks.
Um
with that, let's focus on specifically
one of it. Um I think the thing that I
dislike the most is actually the email
draft. And Dasha and I have a couple
emails that we've sent out. We like
those.
So, why don't we just do something silly
and see if we can make the email draft
better by doing the dumbest thing
possible,
which is first
Oh, wow.
Is the never use few-shot prompting guy
going to use few-shot prompting in this
episode?
I'm going to add a transcript actually
first.
Okay. Okay.
Um now this is not going to work. So,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
to Claude Code and I will tell it
um to um
update
the Python code that calls
email draft to pass in the transcript.
Cool.
And this is I mean, coming back to that
idea of like V0 needing more context
about all your other systems to work
well.
Um I think it becomes like your job as
the prompt engineer to or actually we'll
say context engineer, which is like to
give it a good prompt and then give it
all the context that it needs.
Uh and some of these like coding agents
that run on the CLI like Claude Code or
even Cursor agent, like they tend to be
pretty good depending on the size of the
project. Um it gets a little
uh
tricky, harder, you just have to be more
thoughtful if the project's huge, but
especially for small projects, they can
be very good at finding all the right
context for you so that and kind of
taking that job of like getting all the
right files and pasting them into the
right place.
Um take that off your plate, basically.
Exactly. And now you can see it's
passing the transcript for me
automatically.
And in theory, uh you want to make
sure I don't want to ask again.
to wait.
I just gave it all the permissions.
Let's go.
Um
And now that's actually going to go
ahead and go update the transcript here.
Uh I haven't done a session on cloud
code and cursor, but we probably will at
some point. Dexter was on this yesterday
and I was not about it, but cloud code
is in my opinion much superior to
cursor's agent.
Um
relative
Yeah, we will we will do in the next
couple weeks a deep dive probably into
cloud coding. It'll It'll be a little
bit different than like the like, "Hey,
let's go let's go like really fine-tune
refine a bunch of pipelines," but I
think it could be a fun episode.
Um what do I not like about few-shot
prompting? The reason I think I
specifically say this so egregiously and
so aggressively about few-shot prompting
is a lot of people do use few-shot
prompting as like a crutch to try and
get the model to do what they want
without understanding that they're
actually injecting a lot of bias in the
model.
So, let's say you're building a
healthcare company and you're using
few-shot prompting to teach the model
how to do like um um
like detect the right verbiage from a
doctor.
That could be good or it could be
really, really bad. Like let's say for
example, you wanted to go tell the you
want to talk about like some sort of
like weird liver disease that a person
has and that's the few-shot example you
used. It's a really rare disease. One in
like a million people have it, so it's
really unlikely to impact anything. And
then a customer comes in with the same
exact name as the example in your
prompt.
Uh and your future example.
You're going to have a hard time not
telling telling the model that this is
truly an example and not an example
that's related to that customer from a
different doctor.
It's just a hard
infer meaning from things that you
didn't intend for it to like include as
part of the example. Like that people
named, you know,
people named Sarah are likely to have a
liver a rare liver condition or
something. But like Or Sarah is going to
a different doctor.
Right? Even a simpler assumption, just
the person Sarah is going to a different
is going to a different doctor now and
it's an updated conversation. You're
giving me an example, but it's also an
example about the same person.
And whether or not the model understands
that or not doesn't really matter.
It's just more so just that like
you just have to know the biases you're
injecting. In our case, we know Dexter
and I are recording these videos. We
know our tone is what we want to go and
bet. So if we put a few shot example in
here,
it's just going to do what we want
exactly cuz we're not going I'm not
going to run this on any other videos
but the AI that works videos.
Now we do recordings for our team
meetings sometimes.
If I use the same prompt in here, it
will not generate a good email.
Because I have few shot example that for
that specific scenario. So what I really
really like
is this thing that I like to call
dynamic few shot prompting. Uh
What is it? Workshop.
And that works. It's just that most
people don't do it.
Um
or like partial few shot prompting. So
like instead of actually telling the
model that like, oh,
in this case if I want the model to
really understand that engineering is
only people that actively code. So like
a VP of engineering isn't engineering
their product.
I can write that like this in my prompt
where I don't actually give the full
output in my prompt. I only tell it
like, oh,
because they don't code, the category is
product. I missed out on everything
else. I didn't add any other fields.
So, I'm letting the model really
understand this is truly an example.
It's Even if there's another person
named Vaibhav Gupta,
this even to a human would be clear that
this is an example without having to
read too much into it. The inference
that the default inference is an
example.
And also, you can do more dynamic stuff
like, for example, dynamically change
the name of the If for whatever reason I
know the person is named Vaibhav Gupta,
change this name
to be different for that example.
All right? And that's just things that
you can
you can do
to go to make your few-shot prompts a
lot better. Because because if your
prompt uses Vaibhav Gupta, and then you
pass it a new thing and the person's
name is also Vaibhav Gupta, then it
might assume that it's the same and that
follows that pattern. When really, you'd
basically want to say like, "Okay,
whatever the person's name we're testing
on, make sure the name in the few-shot
example is different before we launch
the prompt."
Exactly. So, you want to kind of find an
I I kind of make it I think the idea of
few-shot prompting is you want to
guarantee the model thinks of the thing
you're providing as an example.
And that is a
Cool tangent.
Sorry.
Uh let's uh let's test this thing.
So, let's add the tran- We added the
transcript part in there. Um and like
now re-summarize
So, the only thing we changed
So, the only thing we changed was we're
using the exact same prompt. We're just
also passing in the transcript.
Exactly.
Okay. And this is going to be really
annoying cuz it's going to it just takes
a while to go run. And while we're doing
that, I'm actually going to go add
something. And it's streaming this out,
so we'll see if this is better or worse.
So, sorry. Did you just retrigger all
the processing for all the drafts,
basically?
Resummarize.
Just for this one. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
For all the drafts and the summary. So,
now it's going to cost me a bunch of
money to run this.
Yeah. So, when you when you do
re-summarize, it's going to re-pull out
the bullet points for takeaways and key
topics, and then it's going to go
because the upstream thing changes going
to go regenerate all the drafts.
Exactly.
Um that's what I have kind of defined in
here. Um
and it just takes a while. Uh I don't
know why the models are so slow this
morning.
Uh but they are. Now, as you can see my
iteration loop here is kind of host.
It's very, very, very slow.
So, I'm going to try and make this
iteration a little bit faster by writing
some test cases.
Now, the problem is writing test cases
is actually kind of annoying cuz I don't
actually want to do this. But these
prompts are better. I actually think
these key points are better than the
previous one. Like it actually got one
of the key things we talked about last
time, which is RTFP, read the effing
prompt.
Um and it wouldn't have
Did you Did you change the summarization
as well? I thought I thought we left the
summarization itself unchanged.
Um oh, sorry. Whenever I do
re-summarize, I actually regenerate the
whole summary as well.
Not just the
Okay, so this is just a second a second
pass over the same data, right? You
didn't change the inputs to the summary.
Exactly. So, I actually I just changed
the email draft one, but I also changed
I did the re-summarize button
along the way.
Yeah. Okay, but but you're talking about
hey, these the fact that these points
are better in this case is just at this
this time the the model happened to pick
better summary points.
Okay. Yes. So, once this email is done,
take it out. And this is why I added the
re-summarize button because like
sometimes somebody's just off.
And I don't really want to think too
hard about it. Uh so, like the easiest
way to
want to try again.
I just want to try again. So, I wanted a
way to re-trigger the pipeline.
And you could do this actually in
because we wrote all the code and we
have full control over the pipeline, you
could actually do this in the code and
say like hey, just run it three times
and show three summaries and I'll just
pick one and then go do the rest of the
pipeline. Like you could you could
implement that pretty easily.
Yes.
Like Claude code could probably build
that for you in 5 minutes.
Um and then the email summary at some
point will finish up.
All the content is ready. So, I have to
refresh. This is the sinking point that
I did not get perfect.
Did this work?
Um, it did not. Let me try re-running.
I think open AI for some reason has been
not working very Oh.
I'm going to do this. Oh, Claude didn't
quite nail it.
It didn't nail it. It's fine.
Um, but while it's doing that, I'm going
to do something. I'm going to add some
observability to my pipeline so I can
actually iterate on it a little bit
faster cuz the prompt thing is going to
be so freaking slow otherwise.
Um, yeah, generated.
Um,
I'm just going to do the dump thing.
Uh, I guess it doesn't matter if you
have an API key. You can just send data
here.
With that.
The AI that works is built on trust,
folks.
Indeed it is. I will stop screen sharing
that while I edit my .env file.
We have some trust, but not infinite
trust.
Yeah. Uh,
Okay.
Okay, so what you're doing is adding the
API keys so that every every AI call is
basically going to be tracked and so we
can
Yeah, and I really What I really
the main thing I really want, to be
honest, is I just want to go see the
logs so that when it goes ahead, I can
go ahead and just like turn it into a
um Yeah, turn it into a test case.
And basically without that, what you
could do is I guess you could like
handcraft a test case by like going and
looking in the database and like
assembling the inputs yourself and then
like writing a test case by hand.
Yeah, but I don't really want to do
that. I just want to use like the real
test case along the way.
Um
yeah, there we go.
Cool.
This should I think be done now. It
should have made some diffs along the
way.
Um
Oh yeah, we forgot the blessing
transcript.
Generate email draft. Okay, cool.
Okay, now we should be able to do
I also made this other reset processing
bug because like sometimes
this button gets grayed out like
sometimes it's in a bad state like it is
right now because I restarted my server.
So it's just a lot of resetting
processing really, really fast.
And now, in theory
Oh, it just resets the state. In theory
this will work beautifully.
Well, we'll see.
Um Starting the animal summarization for
video.
we go. Here we go.
Yeah, so the summarization is happening.
Um so the real thing that I really want
to do now is what I want to do is I want
to focus on two parts. I want to make
the summary as good as possible and I
want to make the email as good as
possible. The only way I can really make
the email very good is by being a really
fast iteration loop. I'm actually
iterating on the prompt now.
Iterating on the UI layer is just too
slow. I can't do that. I I don't want to
build state management record replay on
every single aspect of this. It's just
going to be too slow. So I'm just going
to go iterate on just the email now.
I on the summary side I'll stop
same concepts to the Twitter and the
LinkedIn and all the other stuff.
And the reason that we're not seeing the
LinkedIn
take
What? Sorry, go ahead.
I was going to say the reason we have
Okay, sorry. Go ahead, Dexter.
We got a little bit of light. I just
want to note like we should take some
time at the end just to talk about like,
"Hey, what would be next for this
thing?" And like I I imagine we'll keep
working on this thing and like what
other things do we want this to do in
addition to email and Twitter? How can
we get a little more backgroundy? How
can we catch web hooks instead of like
having to come here and click on stuff?
There's a whole like next generation of
this thing.
Oh, yeah, 100%.
Um Vinay's got a question really fast.
So, we are currently building the
end-to-end pipeline to test this, but
are you also going to do the piecewise
test as well?
I'm literally about to do that right
now. Now, what I want to do for the
piecewise testing is rather than running
the piecewise testing on my own,
Oh, you got another you got another
error.
The cloud code isn't doing this right,
so I'll find this myself.
Uh
command C, command B,
backend.
script mode really fast.
And then it'll yell at me.
Why is it yelling at me?
Oh, is this not awaitable?
There you go. That's why it wasn't
working.
I wasn't calling the right code.
That's good to know.
I think where's the other one that I
changed?
Um sorry about watching me live code. Um
I was hoping to have most of this stuff
done.
But while this is done, let's talk about
what the actual thing looks like. So I
should be able to actually see the
actual test case and I should be able to
go and edit it.
There you go.
So I just Yeah, maybe we just do not the
email one, we do a different one.
Exactly. So we can just say like the
summarize for example.
And then let's just make sure that the
summary is actually good. So let's just
make this a test case. Let's work on
this and now we can go to
So that was really fast. Uh so what you
did was you took a recording of an input
output pair for one of these
calls and generated a test case so that
you can go change the prompt and see how
it affects the output basically.
Exactly.
Cuz what I'm finding now is I have the
transcript, I can go play around with
this. Like fundamentally what I really
need is I need a way to actually go see
if this is actually going to work or
not.
Um
How do I hide Without having to go run
the entire pipeline end to end.
Exactly.
So now what I'm able to do is I can go
see the pipeline, see what it's doing
and then I can just go like
First I can just see what the model did.
It's not like the model's key takeaways
are just smaller than I what I want them
to be. I want them to be like
paragraphs.
So let's just change that a little bit.
And it's not like a
Let's see what the model actually does.
It doesn't seem like the model is
actually listening to me. It feels like
what it's actually doing is jumping it
out, even though I told it to give me an
outline of a very, very dense summary.
Um in the system prompt, so let's try a
different model. Uh let's just swap out
to like Anthropic. Um
I think I have a
custom Sonnet.
Let's see if Sonnet will work.
And so basically you want it before it
starts dumping out JSON, you want it to
kind of like outline its thoughts.
Exactly. Outline a dense summary of the
video,
uh then
answer, then fill out the summary.
Um
So, example.
Um schema. Sure, let's just try that.
Maybe my prompt was bad. So, let's just
iterate and see if I can get the model
to spits out.
It's really wild how slow the models
are. I feel like I'm being rate limited.
And this is Yeah, this is the um this is
that like we covered this in depth in
the reasoning topic, right? Of like how
can you get a model that kind of like
think about it before it starts
generating the data that our programs
actually going to use.
Exactly. So, now it's actually
generating a pretty good dense response
of what it wanted, and then it's
outputting the summary. And I think
we'll see if this actually better or
not. I'll try with OpenAI again to see
what it does. OpenAI parole.
And you can see how fast I'm iterating
here. And what I'm really trying to do
here is I'm trying to figure out is it
doing what I want. Ah, that looks
actually better than other things.
Um
And I can even guide it para one.
para two, para three. I can even make it
write multiple paragraphs by like
telling it what I want it to go do. Cuz
it this this doesn't seem very dense.
So, let's let it go do more along the
way.
Ah, this looks way It looks like it's
better on the right track. Because now
I'm telling it to do multiple
paragraphs.
And so, let's see if it actually
understood it. It still really did do
multiple paragraphs.
Um
So, let's like fill this out.
topic para
Um
topic one
para
topic
two para
Since the videos are
60 plus minutes long
try and have time ranges.
It'll Yeah, it'll it'll it'll get the
gist of what I want.
So, I'm trying to force it to basically
reason more along the way.
And reason the way that I really want it
to go do.
Nope, that didn't work at all. Um
I'll rerun this one more time.
one fast
And I think the other thing that I want
to do
is I want to see
if I can get it to actually listen to me
by making the temp I had originally
deliberately tried to keep the
temperature
uh higher for this kind of task.
But, I'm going to make the temperature
zero now and try this out one more time.
Nice.
Oh, this is sick.
Exactly.
Okay, and then what are we going to go
update the structured outputs to create
timestamps or like chapter summaries?
even need that.
I just wanted to go have this because I
wanted to use this as the summary first
before it actually goes ahead and fills
out main takeaways and everything else
here. But, we could update the
structured outputs also encode encode
time time things if you think it's
useful. So, let's go do that.
Let's change main takeaways to include
time data.
All right.
Um
Uh
I've got another field.
Um
main takeaways
uh
timed data.
timed data
Uh summary.
String array?
Well, the summary can be It can just be
one string.
All right. Okay.
And you can actually see what I was able
to do. It took me a little bit of work
to go get this. And now the model isn't
actually going to go do this cuz it's
like, "All right, I can just reason the
data model." So, it's using the
flexibility
to go do this on its own without really
having to think too hard about this.
Um but
My question I guess and I think the
answer is probably just vibes, but like
how are you deciding whether like what's
what's the real trade-off between having
it do this in the preamble versus having
it do it in the data model?
What's the real trade-off? It's a couple
of things. Um when it does in the
preamble, it's not polluting the data
model yet.
So, it allows it to like just like kind
of have like scratch work when I'm
actually doing work along the way to go
produce some of the results.
And that's the real benefit. Um what I
find is in general Anthropic listens to
instructions a little bit better with
this kind of stuff than OpenAI does. So,
like
I'm going to try to run this again with
like Anthropic.
And it should start sending the data.
Now we're on here. I think we should
have gone another one for email.
Yeah.
Where's the email stuff? Uh
oh, the email London mark. Cuz I I think
I think you probably still have an
error.
Yeah. Um so, now we're actually able to
go do this. It's generating time codes.
It's generating a little bit more
takeaways. It but it still seems a
little very one-dimensional about this,
which is okay.
I might actually be okay with like a
one-level uh summarization here. It's
not It might not be a bad thing.
But I think I got I will get slightly
better key topics and bullet points
along the way
to go do this. Now I I may not want to
call this bullet points. It's like Let's
call this like I mean you assist it like
takeaways.
Takeaways.
Um
description, action items.
Action items,
uh listeners
can Action items listeners
to improve their skills.
And you can see what this does to the
prompt. It changes it to instead of
bullet points, we now have a field
called takeaways. It's an action item
listeners can do to improve their
prompt.
Which I think in general is going to be
very very nice.
So, let's go run this up. I'm also
noticing that the the time data from
Anthropic is uh looks kind of
hallucinated. It's just doing 0 to 15,
15 to 30, 30 to 45.
That's true. Which is probably not It's
probably not good enough.
Yeah, I agree. Um let's see if it did it
this way.
Yeah, it really just broke it down to
almost like 4-hour chunks. And it's
probably I bet what it's doing is
biasing off the 16-minute videos
are pretty long.
Right. Have time in this synced
to the transcript.
Um and this is again the thing we talk
about all the time is like a tight
iteration iteration loop of like if you
were doing this end-to-end testing or
even with pytest without like dedicated
tools, I think this probably take longer
to kind of fiddle with.
No, it sounds like it's still using
those. So, like it this might just be
like a thing Anthropic is going to do
unless I specifically break down the
transcript into like a shorter chunk.
So, we can just try that.
Oh, you want to try a separate method
that chunks the transcript?
Um
like what just like I don't know. It's
like 45 minutes. I
Well, I'm just going to do like the dumb
thing.
And just like command X.
And just run that.
Um and then see what it does.
And it sounds like a it looks like a
little bit
better
uh along the way,
uh but not too much. So, like let's just
leave it for now, and like we'll come
back to this in a second.
But I think the summarizer looks
significantly better at this point.
Um in terms of what we're going to go
get. So, now what we'll do is
update my UI to show the new
Yeah, exactly. It's kind of like if you
wanted to take do a a pre-processing
step on the transcript and really focus
on splitting it up into time chunks and
maybe like chunk it deterministically
and then pass those chunks into models,
you could do that.
Update my UI to show the new time data
in the
um
in summary.
Um cool. Let's go do this. One thing I
like to do when I go do all this stuff
is like this stuff is done. So, I'm I'm
just going to stage this
and then I'm going to go tell it to go
do this.
And now it should be able to go find
this and the time data should pop up in
there. So, I tried to guide it a little
bit along the way.
Um
and it should hopefully be able to go
ahead and see if we can find it.
Oh, this is the first stop animal. Oh,
it's too big for Claude to read it.
Yeah, because of this test case. So,
what I will do
Yeah.
I'll hold it and split a test case into
a
summarized test.bbl.
Which makes sense. Like we will have
a bunch of issues with long-term test.
Continue. I made the file
smaller.
Um so, now that I can just put my test
in here, now this file should be
actually readable. That's actually one
good thing for me to note in general
from now on because transcripts are
going to be long, I should keep all my
tests in different files. In fact, I
probably want each test to be its own
file because I know transcripts will be
long.
Um otherwise, like my AI code gen stuff
will not be able to do it very well.
Yeah, and it's like another thing that I
think would be cool for I putting up
episode is like how do you make your
code base
easy for AI to use? And there's actually
I think a really important balance
between like if you have lots of little
files, like really small files, then
you're going to end up with like the AI
has to remember to read every single
file and the prompting and the tuning is
going to set it to be a little bit kind
of like balanced in how much it reads.
But if your files are too long, it's
also trained to be a little bit
um
kind of
thrifty with how much of a file it
reads, right? The models the the agents
generally try to read like okay, if I
can find the right 100 lines, I'm just
going to read those. And that can be an
issue as well. And I think we found a
lot of success in
what we're doing is like and also is is
in prompting the model to like make sure
it always reads a thousand or 1500. If
it's a long file, read the whole file
because otherwise it ends up like I'm
sure we've seen this in five coding
where it's like re-implement a method
that already existed somewhere else just
because it didn't read enough of the
file to see that that function was
already there.
Exactly. So now I think it should be
almost done.
Um and it it regen the code which it
didn't have to but it did, that's okay.
Um and now it should be able to update
the UI as well.
Um
this is only part of my five point of
time annoying I don't I can't tell it
all the stuff. I think it's all done.
Cool.
Let's go back to the UI and see what
that
So now that we have this, now we can
just
re-summarize.
Oh, failed.
Um oh, I know how my API key burning
topic. Give me one second. Let me plug
that in really fast.
It would be quite funny if um
I did not realize but I was secretly
just sharing all my API keys anyway cuz
I had the screen up. But I think I have
my other screen.
Um
dot end.
And
my API key.
Nobody's back in again.
And now
if I have some more time
and we summarize, it is processing.
And once it's processing, we will be
able to go see everything soon.
Um
while we're going to go do this, um why
don't we use frameworks here? Um I want
to show you the code that we're actually
using to call the AI models just to tell
you an idea of why we don't use
frameworks.
Um
I actually hate this Python code.
The fact that it consumes an editor slot
is really annoying.
Um but when I go down into this
all I'm really doing here is this.
I'm just calling a method that calls
summarize video.
The summarize video is just a function
that I've already defined that takes in
a transcript, takes out a title, and
spits out a data model. The fact that
this uses an LLM doesn't really matter.
I don't really need a framework to go
deal with this.
Um in order to orchestrate it, all I do
at this point is
once the summary is done, I feed the
summary into these three things, and I
just call async io.gather it.
So, like the benefit that I'm getting
from a framework just isn't worth the
debugging headache that I would have to
deal with.
All I really want is I just want to have
functions in after one after another.
And this is one of the like the points I
think we make a lot in um in 12 factor
agents is basically the idea that like
code is already a directed graph, and if
you really like thinking in graphs, you
can use frameworks that give you kind of
this like nodes and edge edges
structure. But what you're looking at,
can you go back to that real quick?
What you're looking at on the screen
is is a DAG. It's like do this thing,
and then fan it out, and do these
things, and okay. All right, I
go back to the code real quick? You do
this thing and then
Um
You You do this thing and then you fan
it out to these three things. And then
when they're all done, then you go to
another step. Like code is already a way
of expressing directed graphs.
Um and if you are able to write code and
do the basics and get maybe get help
from a model in writing the code itself,
then um you should leave yourself open
to whatever approaches and structures
and like now because we control all this
code, if we wanted to like add another
step here that is pre-summary and then
pass the output of that in in addition
to our summary here, we have the
flexibility and the freedom to kind of
architect this however we want. And by
doing weird custom stuff, that's kind of
how you find the boundary of what the
model is capable of and kind of push the
limits of what is possible with AI. Um
if you're just kind of like using a
generic approach, you're going to be
your quality is going to be capped at,
you know, whatever everyone else using
the generic approach is able to do.
Versus if you open the box and start
tinkering with the wires, you may be
able to get better results.
Yeah, exactly. And then the other really
thing important thing to know is like
most frameworks don't actually give you
like full fundamental control of the
full full full prompt. They add some
preambles, they modify how your tools
are being presented because
part of standardizing things, like
passing between open and dropping is
standardizing something.
And while it's true that you may want to
go do that, the problem is the
fundamental thing that you're passing
into the model is these tokens. Like
these tokens Oh, it's going to take
That's going to take forever to render.
I [ __ ] up. Um
Uh running a model on tokenizer in a
browser is not a good call. Uh on very
very long text. But at some point you're
going to call the model in some way and
you're going to want a model to see
those exact tokens.
Your quality is strictly bound by the
tokens you send in and out of the model.
The only thing that configures what the
model spits out is the tokens in and
tokens out.
So, you can't control every token out
there, you can't get it. So, I think
we've had some people, for example, that
live in like other countries.
And like if they if you use a library
and they build a pipeline that's
supposed to speak, let's say, Japanese
or like um Persian or some uh or any
other language along the way, like
Hindi, anything.
If the library injects a lot of English,
the model's going to speak in English
um because it thinks it's allowed to do
that.
And it's really important that if you
have control, you can actually have that
access along the full line.
Hopefully that answered the question,
VJ.
Um and now I think I cancel this again.
Okay.
Third time's the charm.
Cool. What do we want to get through
before we kind of wrap for today and go
to questions?
Um I think we can go to questions. I'm
just going to go I showed kind of how to
make the summary summary slightly better
by going to go down this road. I'm I
want The last thing I was going to do
was actually feed in the email and the
transcript to the email to make it
slightly better, as well.
So, I'll try and get that wired up. And
if I don't get it wired up on the call,
I'll do it afterwards and go send out
the content, as well, so people can poke
around with the prompt. But you saw the
iteration loop of what I do.
I take the prompt. Once I have some
data, I literally just go ahead and like
make a test case from real data cuz I
need to run the pipeline once. I don't
want to have fake data. Fake data is the
worst thing I can do because if I use AI
synthetic data, it's it's going to work
and then it won't work for my real
problem. So, I'll just run the pipeline
once, pay the cost, download the test
case, and then I'll just iterate on the
test case alone until I'm satisfied.
Then have the AI model go fix all the
downstream uh pipelines along the way.
Yeah, and this is kind of what we did in
the emails episode, too, right? Which is
like push real data push a little bit of
real data through the pipeline and then
go look at it by hand and find, okay,
this would make a good test case or this
is a good example of something the
model's not good at. And like part of
baking golden files is about like, oh,
this is a thing it did right and I like
everything about this. Let's cement that
as a test case. So, as I change things,
I know that that one will continue to
work. And then also, hey, let me go find
a thing that doesn't work and let me go
take that down and put it on the
workbench and tinker with the prompt
generator right on it.
Exactly. And I think we might go look at
the new summaries. Like, we've generated
quite a few summaries at this point. I
think this is the most recent one.
Well, it's clearly generating time codes
and everything else. So, the fact that
the UI isn't rendering it means that
Cloud Code just messed up in the UI and
didn't render this correctly. So, I just
need to go debug that and figure this
out.
But, it's really easy for me to like,
cool, the time codes look good and this
is this might be good enough for the
next step of the pipeline.
So, it allows me to just debug really,
really quickly to see what's actually
happening under the hood.
Um with that, let's break for questions
really fast. Uh and if we don't have
any, we'll just keep eye coding for like
next 10 minutes or so.
Um
What do you think about tools like the
Vercel AI SDK that still give you all
that flexibility to do whatever you
want, but also give you tons of helpful
stuff for streaming and tools and UI and
React integration and other helpers and
utilities?
What do I personally think about the
Vercel AI SDK? Um
I think the Vercel AI SDK is okay, to be
completely honest.
Um I think the biggest problem that I
had with the Vercel AI SDK is that one,
it's too deeply tied uh to a lot of
native Vercel stuff. And two, I don't
actually think it captures the nuance of
what streaming actually is.
Um a lot of people think of streaming uh
for structured data to be trivial, uh
but it's actually a really, really,
really hard problem. And I'll show you
why it's hard.
Um and why you can't actually
why it's hard, I I wrote the tool
streaming for VL LM.
So, I like I I I'm familiar with I've
actually contributed to the streaming in
the AI SDK, too.
Um I guess like I I I've used it on
projects where I've never used Vercel at
all. Like, it doesn't force you into
Vercel's ecosystem. It's actually like
totally independent of their platform.
Yeah.
So, I was just curious like cuz it gives
you lots of great stuff for like
generating like if you're doing like
tool calls or structure generation, it
lets you stream that object to the you
know, your React app or whatever and get
a hook so that you can see okay, well,
this is this field has been generated
and now this field has been generated.
And so, you can like make your user
interface interactive as um you know,
like it for example, if you're
generating a complicated object, you can
make your time to interactivity and time
to user feedback faster. Um but I like
it's the one the one one thing it does
force you into is using Zod. Like, it's
very opinionated about using Zod for
schema definition, which is fine. Zod's
a great library. But like I love all of
the great things that BAML gives you for
that. So, I guess like my question is
like
more along the lines of like is that do
you ever see there being like some type
of integration there of of using like
BAML with
We actually have a BAML integration with
Vercel. Um
all you have to do is like So, BAML
under the hood
Next.js, right?
Yeah, we have a function like summarize
video. So, what you can do in your VS in
your code directly like let's say you
wanted to do this all in your front-end
code.
I didn't actually do this here, but I
could.
Um
we also do the thing for you where we
just give you a hook that you can just
use.
import um
uh
Let me do this.
from at
BAML client / react
/ hooks.
So, we have a function here called
summarize video. So, you got to use
summarize video hook.
And then what you can do is const
equals use summarize video.
And then you can have like the data as a
summary.
Or you can have a mutate function and
all the other state associated with it
and you can just go call this with
whatever data you want.
The summary is guaranteed to be a
version of this type along the way.
So, you can do like And the
And the partial type is the thing that
has like based on your bambo code of
like what's what's nullable in a stream
basically, right?
Exactly. So, you call like mutate.
Um and when you call mutate, you get
like a stream object along this um along
the way, but the data object just
updates along the way.
So, data become like a
okay, I didn't know y'all had that. So.
So, you and and like when you do summary
dot, you get like bullet points and you
can notice that all these things get
like optionalized along the way.
But, what I could do is I could say even
during streaming, I want to guarantee
that video summary key point is going to
be
I actually want to guarantee that hey,
when I go send the video summary, I want
key points individually be stream.done.
The The key points field has to be done.
So, or I I can do like
would mean that like this the hook would
not start streaming data until the key
points were all processed and then you
would start getting the partial object
for all the rest of the fields. And the
main takeaways is not. So, the main
takeaway is becomes guaranteed to be a
string array.
Versus if you're trivially streaming,
you now have to go do this and now it
becomes like a very complicated
Everything is Now, everything everything
is nullable versus hey, I guarantee the
time data and main takeaways will always
be true before I hand it to my renderer.
When I stream just this array, this each
string should be individually streamed.
And now, you got to say a different
type, you get an array. Oh, whoops.
That's what I'm doing in a second.
You get an array of like
get an
This should actually work. I'm surprised
that this doesn't work. Maybe the code
gen is wrong for this.
Let me check one more time.
Bullet point.
We're actually in the middle like
redefining our types. Some stuff works
with go, which requires perfectly strict
types and doesn't allow for any
flexibility. So, we're just finding a
couple bugs in there.
But, the idea is like you you have when
you're streaming, you actually live in a
duality of type systems, and that is the
part that people really miss out on. You
really have two type trees you have to
navigate, which is really, really
complicated.
So, having utilities, like you can
actually use TypeScript's partial type
to go do that.
So, then when you go ahead and actually
build something out, you want to go
build like really interactive component,
doing this should be trivial.
Where I built a React component that
analyzes and does this, but you can't
really do that because this is working
off of two type trees.
And that is the hard part. And making
that easy, I think, is something that
Vercel's AI SDK doesn't actually do when
you get to real complicated AI,
real complicated JSON structures.
Because if you have recursive types, you
have nested objects, you can't define
that well in Zod. You really need two
Zod schemas to do that correctly.
Okay, thanks.
Damn.
Um that was that was that was uh welcome
that's that's why we call it advanced AI
engineering, folks.
That was sick.
Um
There's another question. Uh you want to
talk about the email optimization? Yeah,
I want to figure out why that's not
working, but like what we can do here is
like we can just make this test case
really fast. I think Abhimanyu had the
question. Do you want to summarize this
question for me, Dex, while I get this
working?
Yeah.
No, I don't think the question like when
he mentioned about the AI SDK, I felt
that we while we were stripping Bolt
new, which uses AI SDK,
we kind of
touched upon that part of the
the ecosystem, and I personally found
out that there's no way to control what
the LLM produces out when you use Vercel
SDK versus when you use BAML. So,
with Bolt new, the problem always
existed that the model the LLM could
generate anything and worse still,
there's no way to control it. Um so, I
was just want to
object generation?
What?
You mean like structured object
generation?
Like generating Yeah, it totally has
that. It's like generate object and
stream objects. You just give it a a Zod
schema and tell it generate an object.
No, but like the problem is you can't
evaluate the output of like uh
imagine you have you're generate
generating a prompt. How do you
uh
how do you make sure that the
the response is is sort of consistent as
in like um
what we did was basically try to give
examples of uh prompt engineering to the
LLM itself while using the AI SDK. I
didn't see a way of uh the SDK
controlling the response generated from
the LLM in in a way that you can do with
BAML.
Like if you if you get what I mean.
Yeah, no. The biggest I think a lot of
you asked like why can't you use
structured generation? I think that's
what Kyle's question here is, like why
doesn't that just work? The reason that
structured generation really doesn't
work fundamentally is that like for
example, check out this email. This
email that we have is literally
outputting JSON with escape characters
and new lines.
That itself is going to lead to like a
bias in the model. So, what I really
want to do
is I want to somehow tell this draft to
say uh description, use triple quote
strings
uh for multi-line strings.
And now when I go run this, it doesn't
generate escape characters anymore. The
email will just be better because
instead of sampling for the best token
that is possible, I allow the model to
output the best token it actually thinks
is the best.
And that makes a huge difference in
quality for the model. Because when
you're not doing this, Dextra had a
great great visual on this last time,
which was basically saying something
like this, which is when the model goes
and generates a this is the token it
wants it wants to generate a new line
character,
and then there are other characters that
want to go generate like oh, a backslash
or a backslash n or something else along
the way.
When you go do this, when you do
structured generation, you basically say
you are not allowed to generate the new
line character cuz you're inside of a
quotation mark. That's invalid JSON. And
you invalidate those tokens.
We did this a lot in computer vision in
the past the last 10 years where you
like tried to outsmart the model.
It turns out just like let the model do
its thing. The only reason that we have
to do structured generation with JSON is
because we don't have a better parser.
If we had a better schema that we could
go and like parse,
then it would just do the trick for us
and we could let the model do whatever
it wanted.
Yeah, JSON was like totally the wrong
decision for for structured generation
just in general. Like JSON should never
have been the primitive for that. It
should have been like Toml or YAML or
something or it's much more like
Well, those are other
XML, right?
Well, you can't parse XML.
Toml and YAML have the same problems.
Toml and YAML are basically
indiscernible for where they start and
their ambiguity as a starting point is
really really hard to misclarify. Cuz
almost every file is a valid YAML file.
So, parsing that is virtually impossible
because there's not there's not enough
constraints on it. XML has a similar
problem where you run into escape
characters with XML and like the actual
way that you do XML is so nasty. Have
you seen how JSON looks in XML? Like
type systems in XML don't really make
sense. They're too verbose.
So, it's not that there's one answer for
everything. It's just that you want the
flexibility as the app designer to
choose what you want. If your if your
goal as a developer is to generate HTML
code, XML will be a bad format for you.
Guaranteed. Definition.
All right. All right. All right. I'm
going to pause this on the structured
output. This is a dope deep dive. We
have 7 minutes left and we have some
really good questions in the chat. I we
have Derek has a hand raised.
And then I really like Sean's question
as well, which is like how do you keep
your database schemas consistent with
your Babel generated types?
I think that one is quick, right? We're
just dumping JSON B into the database
and and the front end is parsing it
using the Babel library.
But then I want to hear Derek's question
as well.
Literally the types that I save are just
text and I think I just do JSON. I think
I have to actually have a This is not
the latest table.
I had to do some migrations.
Uh where is my migrations table?
Um I added
all of these became JSON B's. They're
just JSON B's. So I just open and close
JSON B files.
Uh JSON B columns along the way. And
then I just cast it because I know it's
correct. The hard part about this is
versioning tables over time, but this is
the same problem that you'd have at
versioning at any other point in your
code base.
Um
we will have a solution for that very
soon, actually. It's going to be really
exciting. That's a separate
conversation.
Uh versioning schemas is really, really
hard.
All right, Derek, what you got?
Just a quick question. You've made me
think um earlier when you were doing the
summarize, I had put a suggestion, maybe
synthesize all of the variable names,
functions aside. Really, it's that first
sentence where you say summarize this.
But then now I was first going to ask
about evals and like an approach if you
wanted to try a few different versions
of that sentence, how would you eval it?
But then now I'm thinking it's more
complex because synthesis because of the
way you've blocked this into those time
chunks,
then it may not even, you know, like uh
synthesize across them. So if this
question's making any sense, how would
you handle that kind of eval it given
that you've taken a chunk approach?
Well, I would just accept the pipeline.
Like I think
Chunked meaning the chunked meaning the
transcript time chunks, so like now
you'd have to look across those chunks
to do a synthesis as opposed to
summarizing each one.
That that's what I meant. So I hopefully
I'm making sense with my question.
Yeah.
No, that Okay, so this was I mean we
haven't actually I don't think we've
actually done that yet. Um but the
proposal was like, "Hey, we could make
the transcript a little bit shorter."
And that may actually not be uh be the
right idea.
Um Yeah, I probably won't do it
basically have us
You basically have to have a separate
eval that is like, "Okay, based on our
chunking prompt and our chunking
algorithm and how do we take that those
chunks and pass it back in?" We're no
longer evaluating just input output
pairs. We're now evaluating kind of a
few steps of the pipeline, which is also
really important to do, right? The best
eval is the one that actually tell runs
your pipeline end to end and tells you
if it's still working. And then you can
go refine down into the smaller level
one smaller chunks of your pipeline and
then individual prompts to narrow down
like, "Okay, what's the thing that broke
this?" But um I think the answer is
like, that's probably not what we would
do.
That was just a proposal like, because
you have control of the pipeline you can
do whatever you want.
I don't know if that's a great answer.
A thumbs up. All right, we'll take it.
Well, so let's actually make the email
better really fast by the way while I'm
here.
Uh email example, we're going to do
this.
Um an example an example create email.
What's this?
So I think his question is now that we
have an automated pipeline or they are
we are they going to get the video
upload now instead of Friday?
No, um because we're going to make the
pipeline good. I think one of the things
I hate as an engineer is I
[ __ ] hate emails. I want emails to be
useful or not at all received. Uh so
Dexter and I actually do some good work
to actually go edit the pipeline to make
the emails good. So like in this case I
literally had an example of here's what
it is.
Fed in the example and it's going to go
ahead and
um
And it's going to go ahead and now read
the prompt. I actually told it a great
example a great email was this.
A great email for
a prior
uh video was this. And now I'll notice
the small things that I noticed
immediately.
Which is these bullet points are labeled
wrong. So, I want to go and like format
these better.
So, let's go do that. Or
like let's just make the prompt better.
And like that's great. I don't need to
tell I don't need to tell it that.
sick.
Um
the topic in this
Again, let's go read this. Looks good.
Main takeaways looks good.
Uh transcript complete transcript
Sick.
Full transcript.
Um we'll go do this. I will probably
move the transcript above the main
takeaways.
Above. Yep.
Because again, the model is mostly
biased by the most recent tokens. So,
I'm going to go do that. I want the main
takeaways to be last.
It's going to go do this. I'm using
GPT-4 mini. Let's just try and see what
happens.
I've heard GPT I've experimented a
little bit that GPT 4.5 is is um
very good at these sort of writing
tasks.
And a couple of things. If you notice,
it said your name. That's a a
a prior video um
create a professional announcement
on behalf
of
Fibob and Dexter. Let's tell it that.
Let's tell it that it's on behalf of us.
So, it can have more context again.
And this is why we can use a few-shot
example cuz this example's a really
really good example for what we want.
In this case, it didn't put a call to
action in the data model. The call to
action's probably done. Are you hitting
context limits on 4.0 mini maybe cuz
it's so long?
I'm not. There's no way. Okay. Okay.
Let's go do this. Let's make call to
action optional.
And it actually seems like it figured it
out. Um we can go read this really fast.
So, this is about dynamic strategies for
effective prompting.
Uh
this is weird.
Um
and last time's video title was actually
we already had a title.
The title was called
um cracking the prompting interview. So,
before I go adding parameter, I'll just
say like
let's just like assume that the title
that I passed in, I can just crack
change this in my test case.
Uh summary
Let's assume that I gave it the right
title.
Oh, at the bottom. Yeah, your title says
Zoom meeting.
Cracking the prompting interview.
So, I'll go run this.
New video really is cracking the
prompting interview. This is pretty
good. It actually got rid of the Zoom
meeting, gave us a slightly better
title.
It actually almost got the exact same
email that we actually really wanted.
Use indexes instead of relying on long
URLs. That's a great thing. Natural
output, let it go in the most natural
format instead of constraining them to
JSON, which is a thing that we should
do.
Really format the structure as you want.
Read the prompt. Balancing
effectiveness. Uh that looks like spam.
Uh real-world applications, that looks
like spam.
Um so, what we can do now is we can just
like compare this to the actual thing
that we sent out.
And we can go see
what it feels like.
And this is the one that we wrote by
hand for this one.
Uh there's a couple of things that
didn't have. Like these One of the
things that we probably like is we like
having code in the emails. Code snip
like small little code snippets in
backticks in the emails. It makes I
think makes it much more authentic.
Didn't seem to capture that.
So, let's just tell it that we like
that.
Um
Uh where did it go? We can tell it this
in the draft.
Um include
code snippets.
Include small code snippets
in the emails.
And it might actually have a hard time
including code snippets cuz it's just
from an audio snippet. So, what I might
need to do is I might actually need to
feed in the video into this as well so
it can actually have video as context
while it does this. So, we should get
the YouTube URL for the YouTube video
and just pass it into the like a Gemini
model and go past that in and that'll be
like the next thing that I'll go iterate
on along the way.
Are you guys understanding how to
iterate on this pipeline and make it
better to make it really feel like
what's good? What's good here I want you
all to notice is Dexter and I already
have done this work a few times. So, we
have a golden target in mind.
If we're working on a data set that
neither of us understands, there's no
golden target and we'll be stuck and we
won't be able to get an answer really
well.
So, we can iterate fast without an eval
set because we kind of understand the
domain of the problem.
Um
Is there any
other questions along the way?
Um
Dexter, anything else you want to
mention?
Um no, the only the other reason why we
can't send this out right away cuz Zoom
takes like 4 hours to process the video
and it creates the transcript. So, Yeah.
that's uh to answer Sudeep's other
question, we will no matter how much AI
we have, we will never send the video
immediately after the call.
Yes, because of Zoom. Um and we might be
able to get get around the one-day
turnaround as well. But again, the whole
point of this is
I I'm going to try to
go present to the AI team at Zoom? Don't
you have like influence over how they
can't you make it faster?
Yeah, let me ping them.
Um but, I think the
Um Yeah, I think the takeaway here is
like, build the tools that you need,
build the workflow first. Once you've
built the workflow, add the AI part cuz
you can decouple that development really
fast.
And whatever I have to do to generate
the email draft, my real suspicion to
make this email really good is actually
I should actually break down the
structure of this email into like
separate sections that we have.
And write a two-step pipeline where the
first step generates all the structure,
then the second step puts it into the
like the language and the floweryness of
what the email needs.
And I think that will make it a lot lot
better.
Um but, I think that's it. We went a lot
a little bit over than what we planned
on doing today.
Um but, this was tons of fun. I have
personally learned a lot building this
whole thing out, way more than I
normally do.
Um
because I learned from Dexter on Vibe
Board. It was amazing.
Um
You were You were pretty good at Vibe
coding before uh when we got started.
No, I I'm not. I think I do a My Vibe
coding is very